New York's Lincoln Center played host to
a sold-out crowd of 2,700 attendees who
came to hear from the world's brightest
financial minds all in an effort to
raise awareness and fund research for
pediatric cancer at the 20th
anniversary's Sohn Investment Conference
to add to the excitement chess
grandmaster Maurice Ashley emceed and
never before attempted timed and unn
sequenced chess exhibition please
welcome one of the greatest chess
players greatest chess minds in history
Magnus Carlsen Magnus Carlsen is the
highest rated player in the history of
chess and on this day he graciously
agreed to donate his time to the Sohn
Conference Foundation playing a charity
match against three brave challengers
simultaneously Magnus you ready for this
I never done this before I wouldn't know
to give the challengers a fighting
chance Magnus played blindfolded forcing
him to visualize the three chess games
in his mind while playing against the
clock gentlemen let the match begin
board 1e for board to D for board one
black played b6 on board two black play
Knight f6 as the match progressed Magnus
showed no signs of struggle as he called
out his moves without hesitation
board one Bishop three all the
challengers are deep in thought
midway into the match board one black
Castle queenside the challengers began
to feel the pressure I was a risky
for 395 Czech and Magnus turned up the
heat metal textbook boredom
one by one board frequent xha the
challengers began to fall that is
checkmate on board three that is one
down to the gutter for one Queen takes
f7 second unlock is down to 13 seconds I
resign Black has design on board one
with the clock running out only Paul
Hoffman remained in the game Black has
eight seconds left doesn't look fun yeah
Queen to d8 he six but time was on
Magnus aside and the time is up Black
has run out of time Magnus wins on all
boards at the end of the day the sonne
conference was a huge success having
raised more than 4 million dollars to
help fund pediatric cancer research to
learn more about the Sohn Conference
foundation and watch the complete chess
match please click on the links provided
in this video's description thanks for
watching